welcome everyone this is part two in our
series on contextual word
representations we're going to be
talking about the transformer
architecture which is the central piece
for all the models we'll be exploring in
this unit
let's dive into the model structure
we'll work through this using a simple
example at the bottom here i've got the
input sequence the rock rules and i've
indicated in red that we're going to be
keeping track of the positions of each
one of those tokens in the sequence
the first step is a familiar one we're
going to look up both the words and the
positions in separate embedding spaces
those are fixed embedding spaces that
we'll learn as part of learning all the
parameters in this model i've given the
word embeddings in light gray and the
positional embeddings in dark grey
to form what we think of as the actual
embedding for this model we do an
element-wise addition of the word
embedding with the positional embedding
and that gives us the representations
that are in green here you can see that
on the right side of the slide i'm going
to be keeping track of all of the
calculations with regard to this c
column here and they're completely
parallel for columns a and b
so to form c input we do element wise
addition of x34 the embedding for the
word rules and p3 which is the embedding
for position three in this model
the next layer is really the hallmark of
this architecture and what gives the
paper its title attention is all you
need we're going to form a bunch of
dense dot product connections between
all of these representations so you can
think of those as forming these
connections that look like this a dense
thicket of them
on the right here i've given the core
calculation and it should be familiar
from part one in this unit it's exactly
the calculation i presented there with
just two small changes but fundamentally
if our target vector is c input here
we're attending to
inputs a and b
we do that by forming the dot products
here and the one twist from before is
that instead of just taking those dot
products we'll normalize them by the
square root of the dimensionality of the
model dk
dk is an important value here because of
the way we combine representations in
the transformer all of the outputs that
all the layers we look at have to have
the same dimensionality as given by dk
and so what we're doing here is
essentially scaling these dot products
to kind of keep them within a sensible
range
that gives us a score vector alpha tilde
we soft max normalize them and then the
other twist is that instead of using
mean here as we did before we use
summation but the actual vector is the
one we calculated before we're going to
take weighted versions of a input and b
input according to this vector of
weights that we created here
that gives us the representation c
attention as given in orange here and we
do that of course for all the other
positions in the model
the next step is kind of interesting
we're creating what's called a residual
connection so to get c a layer here in
yellow
we add up c input and this attention
representation that we just created and
applied drop out as a regularization
step there and that gives us ca layer
the interesting thing there of course is
this residual connection instead of
simply feeding forward see attention we
feed forward actually a version of it
that's combined with our initial
positionally encoded embedding
then we follow that with a step of layer
normalization which should help with
optimization it's going to kind of scale
the weights and these representations
the next step is more meaningful this is
a series of two dense layers so we'll
take ca norm here and feed it through
this dense layer with a non-linearity
followed by a another linear layer to
give us cfx as given in dark blue here
and that's followed by another one of
these interesting residual connections
so we'll apply drop out to cff
and then add that in with ca norm as
given down here at the bottom and that
gives us this second yellow
representation
we follow that by one more step of layer
normalization and that gives us the
output for this block of transformer
representations
and you can imagine of course as you'll
see that we can stack up these
transformer blocks and the way that we
do that
is essentially by taking these dark
green representations at the top here
and using them as inputs and all the
calculations are the same so you might
imagine that we could continue here by
just doing a dense series of attention
connections across these and then
continuing on with the calculations i
just presented and in that way we could
stack up transformer blocks and i'll
return to that later on
there are a few other things that are
worth pointing out that are kind of
noteworthy about this model
it looks like a complicated series of
calculations but i would say that
fundamentally what's happening here is
we're doing positional encoding to get
embeddings so that they are position
sensitive representations of words
we follow that with an attention layer
which creates that dense thicket of
connections between all of the words as
positionally encoded
then we have these optimization things
woven in but fundamentally we're
following that attention step with two
series of feed forward layer steps here
followed by the same process of drop out
and layer normalization so if you kind
of alighted the yellow and the purple
you would see that what we're really
doing is a tension followed by feet
forward and then as we stack these
things it would be attention feed
forward attention feed forward as we
climbed up and interwoven into there are
some things that i would say help with
optimization
another noteworthy thing about this
model is that the only sense in which we
are keeping track of the linear order of
the sequence is in those positional
embeddings if not for them the column
order would be completely irrelevant
because of course we've created all of
these symmetric connections at the
attention layer and there are no other
connections across these columns so the
only sense in which column order that is
word order matters here is via those
positional embeddings
here's a more detailed look at the
attention calculations themselves i just
want to bring out how this actually
works at a mechanical level so this is
the calculation as i presented it on the
previous slide and in part one of this
unit
in the paper and now commonly it's
presented in this matrix format and if
you're like me it's not obvious right
away that these are equivalent
calculations so what i've done for these
next two slides is just show you via
worked out examples how those
calculations work and how they arrive at
exactly the same values i'm not going to
spend too much time on this here this is
really just here for you if you would
like to work through the calculations in
detail which i strongly encourage
because this is really the fundamental
step in this model
and here's all the details that you
would need to get hands-on with these
ideas
now so far i've presented attention in a
kind of simplified way a hallmark of
attention is in the transformer is that
it is typically multi-headed attention
so let me unpack that idea a little bit
concretely we'll start with our our our
input sequence from before and we'll be
looking at these green representations
here
and the idea behind the multi-detention
mechanisms that we're going to inject a
bunch of learned parameters into this
process to encourage diversity as part
of the learning process and they're
really diverse and interesting
representations
so here's how that works we're going to
form three representations here using
that same dot product mechanism as
before and fundamentally it's the same
calculation
except now we're going to have a bunch
of learned weight parameters as given in
orange here and those will help us with
two things first injecting diversity
into this process and also smooshing the
dimensionality of the representations
down to one-third of the size that we're
targeting as dk for our model
dimensionality and you'll see why that
happens in a second
but fundamentally what we're doing is
exactly the calculation we did before
but now with these learn parameters
injected into it so if you squint you
can see that this is really the dot
product of c input with a input as
before but now is transformed by these
learned parameters that are given in
orange and that repeats for these other
calculations
so we're going to do that for position a
and we do it also for position b
and it's the same calculation but now
with new parameters
for the second position
and then for the third head exactly the
same calculation but new learn
parameters up at the top here so this is
three-headed attention and the way we
actually form the representations that
proceed with the rest of the calculation
of the transformer architecture as
presented before
is by concatenating the three
representations we created for each one
of these units so the a column is the
first representation in each one of
these heads
the b column is the second
representation of each head and
similarly for the c column as the third
representation in each one of these
heads and that's why each one of these
needs to have one-third the
dimensionality of our full model so that
we can concatenate them and then feed
those into the subsequent calculations
the idea here of course is that
injecting all of these learned
parameters into all of these different
heads we're providing the model a chance
to learn lots of diverse ways of
relating the words in the sequence
the final point is one i've already
mentioned before which is that typically
we don't have just one transformer block
but rather a whole stack of them we can
repeat them n times for models you're
working with you might have 12 or 24 or
even more
blocks in the transformer architecture
and the way we do that as i said is
simply by taking the dark green
representations at the output layer here
and using them as inputs to a subsequent
block so they get attended to when we
proceed with the subsequent
regularization and feed-forward steps
just as before and when you work with
these models in hugging face if you ask
for all of the hidden states what you're
getting is a grid of representations
corresponding to these output blocks in
green here
and of course just as a reminder i'm not
indicating it here but there's actually
multi-headed attention at each one of
these blocks through each one of the
layers so there are a lot of learned
parameters in this model especially if
you have 12 or 24 attention heads
at this point i'm hoping that you can
now fruitfully return to the original
vasonia all paper and look at their
model diagram and get more out of it for
me it's kind of hyper compressed but now
that we've done a deep dive into all the
pieces i think this serves as a kind of
useful shorthand for how all the pieces
fit together so let's just do that
quickly as before we have positional
encodings and input word embeddings and
those get added up to give us the
intuitive notion of an embedding in this
model
that's followed by the attention layer
as we discussed and it has a residual
connection here into that layer
normalization part that's fed into the
feed forward blocks and that's followed
by that same process of kind of drop out
and
layer normalization
and this is essentially saying each one
of these is repeated for every step in
the encoder process every one of the
columns that we looked at
right and if because then in the paper
they're working with an encoder decoder
model each decoder state self attends
with all of the fellow decoder states
and with all of the encoder states so
right imagine this this double sequence
we have a dense series of potential
connections connections across both
parts of the representation
on the right side when we're doing
decoding again we repeat this block for
every decoder state
and if every state there has an output
as for machine translation or some kind
of generation process then we'll have
something like this output stack at
every one of those output states if by
contrast we're doing something like nli
or sentiment it's a classification
problem maybe just one of those states
will have one of these outputs on it
and then the attention gets a little bit
complicated if you are doing decoding
for a model like natural language
generation or machine translation in the
decoder you can't attend into the future
as you're doing generations so there's a
masking process that limits
self-attention to the preceding words in
the sequence that you're creating